est ce que comme 68% des femmes vous
n'êtes pas satisfait de votre corps
quand vous vous regardez dans le miroir
et break à 68% des femmes avec sur quoi
vous il ya ba oui bien sûr magnifique
comment il est magnifique
alors oui c'est très gentil je
n'augmenterai bien mais vous aimez mais
on a tout sauf à je pense qu on a des
choses qu'on aime pas trop
ouais mon opération à pas très précis
voilà que vous détestez le plus chez
vous par exemple n'a pas voulu zizi je
sais vous êtes deux mois le dow doit à
oui il ya peu de gras dans le xiième pas
oui il ya du travail devant 6 à la du
grade on nous dira kebab c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
mais moins que les mois de mai mois 2
vous en dise et quoi vous et moi j'ai
pas mes jambes du tout mais on est très
complexe et voilà j'ai trouvé très petit
ça va évoluer là je suis mes jambes
mesurer combien année 63 bonsoir j'ai
des talons s'ouvrait sur 5 centimes
manificat 23 ça drôle c'est là où l'on
re médaille en mai mais je peux
comprendre parce que moi aussi je me
complexe et sur ma taille parce que je
fermais 77 joliette beaucoup plus gros
vous la péter vous voulez faire un mètre
75 et moi sommes allés à les bâches et
des santiags me fait chier
oui c'est vous c'est les seins je pense
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis pour elle allait dire autre
chose merci elle non non non je vous dis
pourquoi je dis ça parce qu'isabelle on
se parle beaucoup certains camps et des
années qu'on se connaît et où il est à
chaque fois que c'est ça le diamantaire
temps je vais l'aider lorbek quand je
suis fâché de javerdat de dos voilà
c'est pas que je n'étais alors moi je
vous dit votre poitrine
c'est ça vous êtes comme ça vous va
comme ça non c'est pas parce que je
m'approchais que je vais voir isabelle
je vous jure que vous êtes comme ça et
vous êtes magnifique logo fait ça alors
je vous défends je veux dire qu'ils
avaient défait ce magnifique et il ne
déteste rien quand on me faisait plus
jeune en vidéo ce q c'est le pire qu'on
peut c'est la seule balle était dans
cette école mes frères elle arrivait à
l'est comment on dit parce que d'abord
on se tue mais ils étaient où ça c'est à
dire qu'elle a déjà causé gilbert
montagné c'est une bonne nouvelle
merci hashtag rôle ou alors attendu
voilà vous savez et vous que si vous
aimez rien du tout on était super en
forme était de se la péter luit on and
on and on vraiment j'aime pas du tout
c'est toi le matin la vie permanent
n'est pas quoi n'ai je rien moi je
voulais être grand blond musclé les yeux
bleus c'est raté notre jalousie presse
et une fois que tout le temps je
comprends mieux ne surtout pas comme lui
mais ce que vous avez des crises et lui
ont rien dit pourquoi je parle blu grand
blond musclé comme si elle savait que
ses talents vous non je serai plus viril
quand même nom voilà si je convaincs ça
qu'on va là nous les six champions que
christine vous moi j'aime pas mes
cuisses je trouve trop grosse à nos
recettes savoureuses elle même pas
regardé l'ibama revoir la copie si vous
arrivez vous même et chacun a ses petits
trucs comme et ses amis que christian
meier est magnifique raxit yeux comme
vous elle ferait si beau si voix la
société d'aujourd'hui
si on change sinon son sac il ya pas de
la chirurgie d'ailleurs bas par benjamin
au fond peut-être fait refaire les seins
mais jamais non jamais fini pollution
[Applaudissements]
non ils savent accords croisés de
playtech
j'ai vraiment des [ __ ] vous avez
vous la voulez cheveux le ca y est les
paupières l'épopée nous dit oui il le
dit il le dit